i need a ladder
this will do okay
so i want you to picture a ladder okay
uh i'll repeat all the relevant details
for this later on so don't worry about
writing it right now but suppose the
ladder is 10 meters long okay
use your imagination 10 meter ladder and
it's resting
against the wall and it's on the ground
i'm just raising it so you can actually
see it okay
the ladder is resting on a wall it's 10
minutes long and then as the name
suggests it starts to
slip okay so i don't know it loses grip
and off it goes okay
now the question is if you know
that this end of the ladder on the
ground is moving at a certain speed
let's say four meters per second and
again i'll repeat all the numbers for
you
if i know it's moving at four meters per
second this way on the ground so this is
what i'm measuring down here okay
how fast
is the top of the ladder moving let me
say that one more time okay if i know
that the bottom of the ladder down here
is moving at a certain speed
can i work out
how fast the top of the ladder is moving
okay now i said before this is a lovely
question because it's very simple to
state you can all picture it right now
you've got it all in your head i'll give
you the number so you can actually write
the thing down but it's quite
counterintuitive because at least my
intuition says well if this is moving at
a certain speed like say
four meters per second
then it stands to reason it's not good
reasoning it's actually false as you're
about to work out it stands to reason
the top is also moving at the same speed
right i mean they're just they're
attached to the same thing shouldn't
they be moving at the same speed if we
work through this we're going to find
out that in fact they're not okay and
we're going to work out exactly how much
okay so now i'm going to ask you to pick
up your pen again and let's work out
what the important things are here
the ladder is 10 meters long so let me
say that
wrong color
the ladder is 10 meters long
the bottom of the ladder the part that's
sliding on the ground
is sliding at i think the time the speed
i said was four meters per second okay
so the bottom
is moving at four meters per second
okay
so now the question is
how fast is the top
moving
and i'm going to give you a particular
value for
for where it is which as you'll see in a
minute is going to become important
when
the bottom
is six meters
from i said it was resting on a wall
yeah
so when it's
slid so that it's now six meters away
from the wall
here's my ladder okay
if it was resting like this which is a
bit unstable it would be zero meters
from a walk and you see the bottom here
is on the wall okay but it starts to
slide it starts to slide at a certain
moment this distance here along the
ground will be
six meters okay at that particular
instant
how fast is the top moving okay now i've
intentionally not given you any kinds of
pronumerals or anything like that i
haven't drawn a diagram even though i've
waved this around enthusiastically so
hopefully you can understand the picture
in your head i want you to see if you
can step through this on your own can
you identify what's constant it's what
what varies
where are the rates of changing this i
haven't stated any derivatives or
anything like that you have to work out
yourself
what equations bind everything together
you're going to have to use come up with
some measurement equations
and then can you do the actual calculus
leg work to answer this question how
fast is the top of the ladder moving at
this particular instant in time okay so
there is the scenario i'm going to
encourage you to draw a diagram even if
it's a very simple one
have a shot if you think you've got an
idea um call mrs laser eye over and
we'll nudge you in the right direction
or give you a clue if you're completely
confused okay off you go
i'm really encouraged because um
whenever i sit with
i was um i was at a i was speaking at an
education conference last week and um
there was this researcher there and he
was talking about how
we as learners should think about
mistakes because mistakes or trouble in
a question um can sometimes be really
discouraging like you you know that
feeling when you get something wrong
you're like that's not a good feeling i
don't like that feeling um one of the
things he said which is really really
clever and it stuck with me and i was
like i want to pass this on to my year
12s was that mistakes are a sign that
the work i'm giving you is hard enough
to make you learn
let me say that again slowly
mistakes or struggle just as equally
are a sign that the work i'm giving you
is hard enough
to make you
learn because if you know what it's like
if all i gave you was a list of 100
questions and you just had to add one
digit numbers you could do them and make
no mistakes i'd really hope and i feel
really good like i'm so good at this and
you would learn exactly
nothing right so i'm really encouraged
because i'm seeing you guys press into
this question everyone's a pressure a
slightly different way which i love
i'm particularly going to pick up after
i'm done with this i'm going to pick up
michael's way of solving this because
it's completely well
it's significantly different to mine i
really like it and i'll show you more
than one solution to this here's what
i'm going to ask you to do
when i gave you this question i
deliberately gave it to you without any
kinds of produce or anything with that
so you had to pick for yourself and that
was part of the challenge of the
question
what i want to do for all of us is
underneath where you've made your
solution would you work with my solution
just so you don't get confused with what
variables or what what letters and all
that kind of thing and you can compare
with whether you like yours better or
mine but at least this way you will all
be on the same page you won't get too
confused okay i'm going to show you mine
and then i will quickly tease michaels
for you
so the first step that i suggested in
our overall strategy was to identify
constants and variables and this is the
first hurdle okay so you got your ladder
here right and this ladder is 10 meters
in length
is that a constant or a variable
this is a constant at least i haven't
said it's one of those weird telescoping
ladders that gets longer and shorter
it's just 10 meters okay it's always 10
meters but then when you have a look at
the other things you're going to
introduce into this
these other things like say how high the
ladder is off the ground or how far away
the ladder is on the sorry yes on the
wall and how far away is on the ground
these things here
they actually change so don't write this
down but i saw a lot of you write six
here
now there's nothing wrong with saying
six it comes from something that is said
in the question okay but i'm going to
encourage you not to just say six
because the second you do that you are
describing this thing down here how far
the ladder is away from the wall you're
describing it as a look
is it a constant or a variable
you're saying it's a constant it's 6
but it's not
it's a variable does that make sense so
you need to give it a pronumeral you can
call it anything you like i saw lots of
different things you might have called
it a and b because you know pythagoras
which is going to come in a second you
might have called it x and y protip for
you if you call things x and y make the
x the horizontal one and the y the
vertical one just so your brain doesn't
fizzle out over confusing which is which
i think x is fine
i'm going to call it x meters here okay
so there's a variable there's one more
variable that's important to me where is
it
you all have it you all gave it a
different name where is it on the
diagram
can you put your hand to show me where
does it where does it look it's that
yeah there you go i can see that that
vertical length over here and it's also
variable right you can call it anything
you like a lot of you call it y which
i'm totally okay with i just i was
solving this and i just called it h
for height
call it whatever you like okay
all right i've identified my constants
and my variables
at least when it comes to the lengths on
here there's actually one more constant
that i need which is actually stated in
the question can you tell me what the
constant is
four meters per second and as i even
sort of clued you into over here it's a
rate right so which rate is it have a
look what's the derivative that goes
with it how would you state it in my
question
yeah it's dx
on dt right dx on dt one of the ways you
can know you're on the right track is
that you've got
the dx corresponds to these meters right
and the dt corresponds to the seconds
the units should line up with your
derivative so that's
dx on dt you happy with that